[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
charisse
is an associate professor of
communications at the s.i newhouse
school of public
communications at syracuse university
she holds bs degrees in brain and
cognitive science
and comparative media studies from mit
um i i i'm assuming that you were one of
the earliest
majors undergrad majors in cms
technically my degree says humanities
because cms was not yet
a labeled major so i do have a
bachelor's of science in humanities from
mit it's a very proud piece of paper i
keep on my wall
so you were ahead of your time uh there
was i think
four of us who graduated in my semester
one of which is in our attendees
um but yeah there's only yeah there's
only four of us who graduated my
semester
i think it became a named major two
years underground major two years later
so maybe 2005.
oh wow great well um
so uh then charisse went on
um to get a master's degree from the
school of cinematic
arts and a phd in social psychology from
the university of southern california
sharisa's work focuses
on how media affects the way we think
about ourselves
and others as well as how we use media
to construct
and reaffirm positive identities her
most recent book
20th century media and the american
psyche
about which she'll be speaking today
investigates
changes to the communication environment
over the past
150 years and how these
rapid yet pervasive shifts have affected
our psychology
at syracuse university charisse teaches
classes on communication and diversity
to professional media students
specifically how to do media how do
media affect
our understanding of different social
categories
and how do the social categories of
media producers
affect the media with which we all
engage
she has mentored over 50 mcnair scholars
across disciplines at the university of
southern california
loyola marymount university and syracuse
university since 2008
and was awarded teacher of the year from
the new house graduating class of 2017.
so welcome or welcome back
thank you it's very exciting to be here
i feel like my face is a little red
so maybe i'll pull that down a little
bit um
yeah no i thank you so much for having
me thank you so much for continuing to
do great work
and um i'm sorry i probably
looks even worse um yeah i'm i cannot
express how excited i am
to be invited to this
colloquium and to talk to all of you
today
i feel like even though my phd is in
psych
the role of
comparative media studies and frankly
mit in general
um really
impacted the way i think about the world
and the way
i approach uh questions
just as a whole and i feel really lucky
to be able to impart this
um these critical thinking skills to
students across disciplines
and today to professional media students
um shall i begin i'm sorry i just kind
of started diving into things okay cool
um i will say that when i graduated from
mit
in 2003 my um
i really wanted to be the head of
programming for mtv
and that was my dream job i thought i
could make
mtv a better network um
by producing better programming and
encouraging audiences
to demand more um
i didn't even know how to apply to a job
at mtv i think i applied to a whole
bunch of jobs when i graduate i was
completely lost
and since then like my overall
goal in leaving or at that time
you know 18 years ago this dream can now
draw this dream can almost vote
um was to make media better to make to
improve the media environment and i feel
like i really had that opportunity
specifically with
teaching critical thinking skills to
media producers so i knew how students
can't major in theory they major in
broadcast journalism newspaper
journalism advertising pr
television radio film or like um
photography and multimedia design
so by imparting these skills to people
who are actually going out and making
media and affecting the discourse i feel
like i'm really having
a direct impact on the quality of media
and fostering producers that can create
content that is disruptive and
encourages other people to think more
deeply
about uh media and the world in which
they live
so that's i do so that's that's kind of
i don't know if that's an introduction
but it's a real context for
uh what i've been doing over the past um
18 years and
for and i assume everyone took a read to
the scan took a listen that was
thoroughly enjoyable
so out of curiosity quick show of hands
how many of you listened
to the thing okay cool and how many of
you read it just okay a few other few
different ones okay cool thank you
i'm really curious as to the
experiential difference
in these spaces around um
in this case audio only media versus
visual media i feel like um i make the
argument in the
third second chapter uh second chapter
section one
on the role of uh the power of audio to
um enact enable
activate feelings of presence uh and the
way in which we have become so
accustomed to having for example
our favorite musician in our home
in our bed in our shower with us in the
car right singing just to us technically
they're singing to a whole bunch of
people but they're singing just for us
and that um that personal intimacy
that comes with uh audio media is
frankly 150 years old and yet it has
become so
normalized so it was a delight to
read that and create that content and
thinking well this is
for everyone but knowing that
people would be listening to it by
themselves so um you know you spend so
much time writing a book
and putting all your words into happy
little text and then to suddenly
hear yourself talk through it is um
it was it was really striking and kind
of an embodiment of the claims that i
make in the book in the first place
um but i did get an email from a buddy
of mine who was reading it was like
reading this book is awesome it feels
like i'm in a conversation with you
and so um you know being able to
actually
bring that to fruition through the power
of recorded audio
um i talked about recorded music but in
the power of recorded audio
um was a delightful opportunity
so um well what i had promised to you
today
in the talk was to kind of um
talk a little bit about the book but
also to
um chart
this sort of cross-methodological
journey
and so i use the term
cross-methodological more than mixed
methods
because traditionally speaking when we
say mixed methods we're saying you know
i'm doing a study here in this fashion
in this fashion and in this fashion uh
and combining uh
multiple methodologies uh into one
larger study
when i say cross methodology i literally
mean well what did we learn
from this method and how can we combine
this method with this other method to
get at
um a more nuanced explanation of some
global or psychological or media
phenomenon
um and i will say you know i feel like
it's an absolute privilege to be able to
do that especially when we talk about
academia that's so
desperately siloed right that if your
methods don't fit into the methods that
have been done
that may work against you later um so i
i put that out there that it's very much
a privilege that i've had the
opportunity to do this and i've had
um advisors
in including professor revell i've had
advisors
um who have been
supportive considerate and always
willing to remind me
about what is gonna work and what's not
gonna work despite what i want to do um
and so i'll just briefly talk about some
of the research that i've done
and i've got some slides on um
the kind of my current stuff and it's
kind of
cross methodological approaches and then
i could talk a little bit about what as
media psychography
is and the goals of the book
itself and then i'm happy and excited
to talk about your research um like i
said
or um like professor bald said i am
i've mentored dozens of
mcnair scholars mcnair scholars i don't
know
if they know what a mcnair scholar is
okay mcnair so mcnair is the ronald e
mcnair program we don't have one at mit
uh which is fine it'll become ironic
as soon as i tell you why but ronald e
mcnair was
a phd graduate from mit uh first black
man in outer space
um it was not george clinton
or sunra don't worry about those are
jokes at the expense of afrofuturism
uh so yeah first black man in outer
space and he died on the challenger
and so it's a federally funded program
to encourage
students of color first young college
students low-income students to pursue
phds and pursue research
so i've had the privilege of working
with literally dozens of students who
are not generationally familiar with the
phenomenon of research but are very
excited about it
and what i've noticed in these
conversations is this eagerness to
answer
questions that have come through their
mind through their lives come through
their eyes
in unique ways but also a
general frustration with the structure
of um of what is traditional research
right so i've spent a lot of time
talking students through you know
sociology students history students
media students psych students business
students engineering students
through uh ways in which to answer the
questions that plagued them
in ways that will fit into
simultaneously the expectations
of academia and to fulfill their own
to seek out the answers that they find
most
fulfilling um i will say and i talk
about this at the
book you know like um just those early
observations that first time when i had
a real
epiphany about media biases
when i realized that little boys were
always the ones who screamed
i won in game commercials and it's funny
because they always had these very
diverse groups
sure whatever you know they had racially
diverse groups they had gender diverse
groups they
generally did not have ability diverse
groups so we can talk all about that and
levels of um
dimensions of diversity but by 1990
standards
they had diverse groups um but it was
always the little boys who jumped up and
said i won
and i just i noticed this then i started
tallying it
right so i was doing little content
analyses in my notebook next to my
lisa frank hearts you know and i was
just so incredibly bothered by this and
i had
teachers that i would go in and say this
is ridiculous this is absurd i'm certain
i didn't use the word absurd
in fifth grade but uh and they're like
okay you're absolutely right
let's write a letter to milton bradley
um and
you know just that moment of seeing this
phenomenon
in the world documenting it coming back
to our
scientific method uh documenting it
observing it and then starting to look
for it in other pieces
is such an essential piece of um
not just research but surviving and
moving through the world as a human
that um you know we can start to see how
we all do it and the question comes down
to when is it fostered and what is it
not
and as i said um coming to mit it was an
absolute privilege
to almost never hear somebody say
that's a stupid question and i'll say
this i heard that a lot
a lot growing up um was that's a that's
a stupid question
um in fourth grade we got to take chess
and the teacher teacher um
uh restricted me to three questions a
day because i asked too many questions
so then i became like really paranoid
about asking the wrong
questions and being really conservative
about which questions do i ask is this a
good question is this a bad question
um in ninth grade i apparently would ask
questions for which the answer was on
the board
and then the teacher started calling
them cherie's questions
in my math class and then she told the
next teacher so that when i went up to
10th grade that teacher was already
referring to unnecessary questions as
cherise questions
um and then and so that is kind of kept
going for a while
because then i became that girl um but
when i got to mit nobody ever said
that's a stupid question
and regardless of whether i was that's
not true
i definitely heard that from my
classmates i had a professor say that's
a stupid question
um and so this
willingness to think differently and ask
more questions and
not be satisfied with the answers that
you're getting i think are
so essential to um
life and then when we talk about media
as this is comparative media studies
um the extent to which we've been asked
not to question media is
really striking right that and as
somebody who teaches media students now
media producers
asking why something is
is not necessarily a good use of time
when you need to
turn out an article in 24 hours it's not
a good use of time when you need to turn
out a news package in
12 hours right media moves so fast
that we're not allowed to even stop and
think more deeply about it
and so that was part of what brought me
to this exercise
actually before we get to that going
through um
[Music]
mit i was a course seven
which is biology um i wanted to be a
geneticist i went to all those nerd
camps in college at like brown in
colombia
and did genetics and then i got to
organic chemistry which was 512 and it
kicked my butt
because organic chemistry is not
chemistry it's physics and i suck at
physics so
that happened um i ended up dropping out
of school because i was
in a not a good position for a wide
variety of other reasons i actually
started
college i actually started mit at 16. um
wouldn't recommend it um but
not necessarily because 16 is inherently
a bad number but
um my mother was very protective so when
i went to college
it was like the first freedom i ever
experienced and it was
it was a lot there so anyway i ended up
dropping out of
school without real direction and work
suddenly becoming hard
and then i had this epiphany with which
the whole book starts and i went back
and um got degrees in brain and cog
and media studies and for me i was
always asking questions across these two
disciplines
um you know using
brain and cog to think about media using
media to think about brain and cog
one of my favorite course nine papers i
ever wrote was for animal sex behavior i
don't even remember who taught the class
i should look that up
and i wrote a paper on the multiple
mating habits of human beings
and basically closed it with a critical
psychological investigation of
pimpin culture which was quite big at
the time you know um
50 cent pimp jay-z all it was really big
in um in the pop culture and thinking
through
how women are framed as a commodity um
both in the animal world the bigger your
harem
the you know more impressive male you
are and applying that
to um mediated culture
i got to see in that class but it is
still my favorite paper
um so then when i graduated
from mit i tried to write a book called
the media made me crazy
um it was going to be a critical
autobiography about how the media caused
me
such emotional strife
i wrote up a proposal i sent it to david
thorburn david thorburn responded and
said it was the most naive thing he had
ever read
i broke down in tears and realize i need
to learn how to write
so i went and got a masters at usc in
critical critical studies
in the school of cinematic arts and then
a phd in the social psych department
and again i was privileged to have
advisors my advisor was steve reed
and lynn miller who's in annenberg at
usc
um never tell me no
and um even though steve's area
steve reed's area was not media
he was constantly just saying okay if
that's the question you want to ask this
is how we will answer it from a
psychological perspective
and that was that kind of support
is what i try to bring not just to my
students but also to myself
so this book now the psychology of 20th
century
media or excuse me 20th century media
and the american psyche
the goal is really to think about
how these new communication capacities
the ability for us to be
looking at each other in real time
miles apart
is remarkable and frankly there's been a
lot of discussion about like how zoo
popped off out of nowhere but now
literally within a year
since pandemic and we can talk about how
pandemic accelerated everything
zoom is now a verb right it took google
at least 10 years to become a verb now
it's you know we we expect to zoom
in fact i think no it wasn't with uh
first of all i was calling somebody else
um and we had a zoom meeting and i
called him on his phone
and he's like oh are we doing this on
the phone i'm like yeah i'm in the car
we're doing this on the phone
and like just the idea of going
backwards in communication strategies
was so foreign right we're always having
meetings
on the zoom now um i also like to say
the
before platforms it makes me feel
delightfully old
like the facebook and the twitter um
so really thinking through these
technologies that have become so
ingrained in our lives the phone uh
the ability to connect with loved ones
and talk to them in real
time across distance
again is frankly only about less than
100 years old when we start to look at
how quickly it was adopted and when it
hit saturation and so on and so forth
is less than 100 years old but it has
become so
normal to the point where my
three-year-old is like yeah let's call
so-and-so
right and so i really wanted to think
about this this
historiography or to do a historiography
and i i'm probably using the term
incorrectly but i really like it
to do a historiography of how media
has impacted our psychology over time
because
psychologists for the most part are so
distanced from history
they really like to say you know this
is what we do this is how we think
and kind of map that on to how we have
always thought but one of the arguments
i make in the
interview with henry i think that was
also shared is
so much of psychology is based in people
like manipulation psychological
manipulations are based in
media usage so reading a passage and
then manipulating this passage to
feature one
name or another a different argument
showing you a picture
right all of that has become so
normalized
but literally 150 years ago literacy was
way low
way down and we didn't have photo
realistic pictures
so everything that we measure in
psychology is largely based in a world
that we have forgot
is based in today and we've kind of
forgotten about
what happened before the world we live
in today existed
and so that was always very troubling to
me and especially as we talk about it
with media
you know that communication specifically
communication technologies in this case
mass media for the most part
media that um disseminate mass messages
are um they're so new
they're very new we talk about just a
blink in the human eye
and you know human history they're new
and yet they're so normal
and so it was a delight to sit down and
kind of
collate all of this research in a
conversational way to think you know
how do these technologies actually
impact us
and um change how we engage with the
world and how have they done that
so remarkably in such little time
so i'll just say and and then i can
pause
or stop um i don't want i
i want to answer questions like i want
to um make myself available
and hear about the work you guys are
doing um y'all are doing
i read somewhere i was like oh y'all is
a much better term than you guys
um let's see here
oh oh hold on let's see sure
so um as we think about this i'll just
hit a couple
quick slides when we talk about a media
psychography i'm talking about the
examination of how the collective psyche
impacts and has been impacted by media
psychologies
by media technologies so literally
looking to our own history with media
how did you come to understand yourself
through the communication technologies
that have become available to you over
your lifetime
it's very easy for us to talk about how
writing or reading impacted us
but we often don't um think about the
other dimensions
uh the other technological affordances
so by looking to our own histories with
media rather than succumbing to the
allure of newness i think this is right
out of the intro
we can further unpack relationships that
users develop with media and provide
insight into how people might build
future mediated relationships so this
whole book
also is rooted in a class that i teach
called psychology of interactive media
ask students to production students to
think upstream
about why people use media so that we
can anticipate
what people might do downstream
um and i'll just i'll close with i'll
stop talking with this one i can also
show you my um
lovely little actually i got a couple a
couple more
um let's see
um i'll just all
come here
that um yeah i had a whole order and
then
i'm not using it so i apologize um i
will say
so for those of you who read it i didn't
technically include the images
or describe them so that's on me um
but this is also basically my
argumentation that we have a new
technology that's developed
this technology enables novel strategies
for communication
um widespread adoption of the technology
then those novel communication
strategies become social norms
social norms change culture customs and
institutions and then we demand
new communication strategies which
relate to new technological development
um i will say as we think about
sorry as we think about i'll close with
this slide
um as we think about oh this is terrible
all right well it's fine um it's just
very small so i apologize
um as we think about the different ways
um media
can be conceptualized um i can't i
argued for this fit taxonomy let me see
if i can get a better picture
okay that's not working anymore all
right
no okay um let's get a better picture if
i stop sharing
yeah that's it it's just missing
um as we think about technologies
um
we can start to break them down into
different
structures so what i'm going to do is
actually i'm just going to zoom in here
and then blow this up for you
i apologize again for not having
a better image
okay so um that we have a format it's
non-visual audio
static text static images synchronized
video and interactive video
and whether that's delivered in analog
electronic formats or digital formats
and then we get into industry and
content journalism advertising
entertainment and peer-to-peer
so we see in this graph in this image we
see that the gray areas are basically
areas where there is no research on the
impact of race and gender
in those dimensions in those media
platforms um
and so we start to see when we think
about media differently where
the questions have been answered and
where they have not
and i think that that's a really
important um
component for any media scholar to
consider is
what questions have been answered but
more importantly which questions were we
unable to even consider because we
weren't thinking about media in this
format
um so i can stop here this probably
seems like a good place to stop i could
also walk you through the outline of the
book and the different claims that i
make
um in the three different sections
intimacy regularity and reciprocity very
briefly i'll show you this
this happy little graph which is what i
presented at mit
10 when andrew and i met
in 2019 but basically i make the
argument that
um intimate media like theatrical film
recorded music and consumer market
cameras
as well as regular media so media that
is integrated into our daily lives
uh like radio network television and
cable television
and reciprocal media so media that
responds to our actions like magnetic
tape video gaming and dial up isps
um all impact 21st century media
practices
and we can only see how they do that
by spending more time with media that we
effectively now call defunct
let's start with that i like the word
defunct so
i'll happily pause here stop here um and
invite questions thoughts hear a little
bit about your research
um uh or we i can keep talking so i'll
throw to
uh professor bald too um
and to moderate from here thanks for
letting me tell my story though
thank you um i i wanted to
just ask um
with regard to um
in the introduction you you talk about
you know the this historical process of
of
um you know of
groups of people becoming accustomed to
particular
particular forms of interaction around
particular forms of media that then um
that then conditioned the way that we
understand and use initially new forms
of media
um and there's there's sort of a
a back and forth between um
what your what you're describing as
as new and what you're describing as
as old right um that there's not a
um not a clear break but this this kind
of um
uh ongoing process of
or cycles of adaptation and change
um and so i i just wanted to ask if you
could talk a little bit about this
um the tension between sameness and
newness
right that that sort of appears in in um
in what you're describing um and there's
there's sort of a follow-up question too
about
um uh
about generations um but but we can get
to that in a second
okay cool because i was about to start
writing down your questions once you get
into two parts i'm like oh i gotta write
that one down
um so same same but different i think is
one of my favorite
adages that um somebody said i think it
was on
i think i was traveling with some
aussies and they kept saying same thing
but different
um i know i think it was brits same same
but different
um so i will say and one of the points
that i make is
i only ever use new and old as relative
terms right one media is newer
in the grand timeline of things than
some other medium
um i try not to categorize
media as new but at the same time
new technologies rhetorically speaking
we use new technologies
as an easier way to fulfill old habits
right so reeves and nas say uh new media
engage with old brains
uh that we use new media to fulfill old
habits so when the cell phone was the
cell phone it was a phone
and like we got to use a phone wherever
we wanted to use this phone and
then we learned that there was this
thing called text messaging
and americans were way late on that game
right because we were so concerned with
using the phone as a phone
um and now we don't even use the phone
as a phone anymore because
uh these these other opportunities email
social media video games all of those
things um become the dominant use of the
computer in our pocket even though we
still technically call it a phone
so um i think that to come back to
what i was starting to write is the
tension between the idea of sameness and
different
is that um we
and this is the claim i make about it
being in a relationship with media we
lead
in every in every new relationship we
expect to at the very least have all the
good
things that we had from the last
relationship and so
that's that's the baggage we bring to
every new relationship and i
probably shouldn't use baggage so
flippantly
but you know that's the baggage we bring
to every new relationship
is the joys and fears of our last
relationship and i argue that if we
think about media technology in that
relational lens what is the baggage that
we're bringing to every new relationship
and how does that impede us
frequently from being able to see the
potential
everything in this new relationship that
could happen
when in reality we're looking at this
new relationship through the lens
of our old relationships and if we map
that onto media
how are we looking at this new
temporarily
temporally right time wise new media
medium through the baggage of our old
mediums
and i think that
that baggage of our old mediums is not
just how we engage with the technology
but it becomes
a way of understanding ourselves right
there's what you bring to every new
relationship
is a residual from the old relationship
but it's a residual of the old
relationship because it
still resides within you and so that's
basically the argument that i'm trying
to make that with every new
technology the only constant is us
and in that concept but that constant
itself has been evolving
because we have all been moving through
these technologies arguably together
um for as i argue in this case 150 years
and earlier does that answer your
question
yeah and it kind of it connects um
somewhat to the second part
um which is that that um
you know also in the introduction you um
you speak about you draw a distinction
between
different um you know regions of the
world for example
um that are differently resourced that
have different
modes of or amounts of access to
different kinds of technologies
um and you um draw a distinction in
terms of
the being able to um sort of make
make statements about the psychological
um relationship to media in one place
based upon
another right um you sort of caution
against that
right um what what i was curious about
in reading that and thinking about um
uh the the like aspects of generational
change
is um
is that you know what you're describing
in terms of
um you know bringing the baggage of our
past
media use to each new medium
of course generationally there will be
you know folks younger than us whose
engagement with with the new media is
actually their
original engagement right um
to to the extent that um
in some ways you might argue that that
uh generational differences might
start to look more like the kinds of
um geographic distance differences that
that you are um are speaking about as
well
and i was wondering you know about um
about that or you know what can we say
about
um you know is there a kind of
essentially
different psychological engagement
with technology from
one generation to another i mean i would
say yes i will say i'll make a point
that i do caution against
generalizing um a small sample
right because i ever since i read that
weird article from heinrich
at all heinrich something and nora zion
um i apologize for forgetting the second
author but
um that weird article about social
science
and that is that social science
researchers look at
western educated industrialized rich
democratic nations
and that and then they go and say oh
this is generalizable to everybody
like as somebody who has largely been
outside of the intersectional space that
is
generalized and as somebody who has been
taught to study those
who are in that intersectional space i'm
very salient
um it's very salient to me about what i
should and should not be generalizing to
by which i mean to say i've definitely
had reviewers ask me where my white
control
is right why don't you have a white
control when i'm doing research
literally on black and latino
populations um i've
looked at my own data sets and just seen
a dominance of white women
in the case of psych research uh
that are at private institutions
studying college right like this
sample is so narrow so i'm just always
very hesitant of saying
that this is generalizable to everyone
at the same time the whole book is
called the american psyche right
um having said that i try to acknowledge
my own generational situatedness like in
the very first paragraph this is where i
am um and i tried not to include it
just in the interest of you know privacy
um
but i do talk about it in the third part
with henry about watching my own child
um engage and like
my husband and i my husband is five
years older than i am right my husband
and i are sitting here just like
watching him come up on the alexa and be
like alexa
i want this song and alexa just plays it
i will have you know that he has now
discovered who let the dogs out
and so that is playing on loop in our
house which is not cool
and in case you don't know about it that
song is totally about sex
and it makes me very uncomfortable but
he
loves it and you know it's
it's just remarkable to watch his
desires be met immediately
and us know that when we were his age
the only desire that could be met
immediately
was probably the book that was on the
floor right but he
his infinite desires are met immediately
and
he will grow up with and we're just
trying to instill
you know some level of delay
gratification
i'm just trying to run him through the
marshmallow test every few days
but um because everything is so
immediate to him
i can't even begin to think about what
his generation will be like when it
comes to this
expectation of on-demand like we came
into on-demand culture we came to
understand it as adults we're like oh
i could watch this now instead
this new generation is like i should be
able to watch this now
i am guaranteed to watch this now how
dare you not let me watch this now
um and i'm i'm fascinated by it
um i do think that generational
differences because of the speed at
which
things advance do have the power to
become
divisions on par with geographical
distances and geographical distances
seem to be collapsing
right so our understanding of different
groups of people and what we have known
groups of people to be
geographically disparate for example um
what's his name is it friedman who wrote
the world is flat
right um that the geographical distances
have fallen
have have become less impactful um
less impactful still less impactful
um whereas the generational differences
become striking and it is left up to us
you know a generation coming into
content
to move faster because the generation
born into the content right what is it
um
um digital natives that the phrase they
use um
uh and that's got all sorts of problems
onto itself but let's keep going for now
um like their expectation of what is
normal in the world is something that we
have to learn
to be normal and i think that um
i think that that difference has the
power to have some
really interesting and important
intergenerational conversations and
connections
it just doesn't seem as evident when
you're
you know when your child can do more on
your ipad than you can
um well let me let me open things up um
to questions from our students or
from um from our attendees via the q a
i'll also while we're thinking about it
i'll just go ahead
and just describe
just give you a little bit of some of
the research that i've done most
recently um
very briefly so my research interests
fall
across representation of groups in media
content using media to construct
identity and disrupt discourse and
testing the potential of technology and
these are some of the pubs
um an auto ethnographic textual analysis
of all american girl
qualitative analysis of caribbean
uh multiracial caribbeans and how they
use social media
satirical education or educational
satire learning and laughing on last
week tonight i'm actually working on a
textbook right now on satire and
diversity
so that's pretty interesting um a
content analysis
of early youth created music videos on
youtube
uh avoidant engagement which is a
collection of quantitative studies
arguing for a theoretical and practical
model of interactivity and persuasion so
basically what happens when you can skip
ads it makes you like the platform more
and hate the brand
like the platform and hate the brand and
then uh this is a fun little
cross section when we look at it
qualitative quantitative or critical so
these are just some of the things i've
been working on over the past couple
years
and the diversity of um
research questions but in the end all of
them are to get at the same question
which is
um to talk about your slip of the tongue
at the beginning
how do we media right how to media how
do we media
so um i was still readable awesome
i think that was my uh i'm sorry i'm bad
with chats
i think that was my table from forever
ago thank you andre
um questions thoughts
angry rejections of my theory
uh i want to go with tomas can you
pronounce your name for me
um and yeah the question was around that
about pronunciation um so
um so something that we've been thinking
about lately in
in the department we have a small
reading group that's concerned with
latin american
media studies just reading media studies
from latin america
and understanding how this traditional
media studies uh kind of goes with
all the american studies with
understanding cultural studies and that
kind of stuff
and i i understand your work goes in
these directions right you
address terms of latinx media and those
things that i think the last two years
are
getting more and more attention and i
was wondering if you give some insights
on
whether um where do you see that going
if you think there's uh how do you
approach uh
um understand latino audiences and and
maybe if we were thinking about
uh what advice you could give to
students who are approaching these
topics maybe
sure thank you i will say that um
my expertise is in um processes of
subgroup
media so i will i will outright say that
my expertise is not in latinx media
um i do look at subgroups um
specific and how subgroups use media so
if we were talking about
how uh observations of latinx people
in the united states i'm not going to
talk about um
in latin america because i i will not be
able that's not my expertise and
i hope that my perspective and
methodology inspire you to
ask similar questions around different
um media practices
um i think a big piece of how we're
talking about
it um i i will also say so i do have
work on
multiracial caribbeans but my family is
british caribbean i'm british guyanese
uh so it's always funny because people
like oh you're from south america so you
must speak spanish i'm like
no you don't you've missed some points
here
that it's a much more complicated thing
then you've come from this geographic
region therefore you must be this
um but and i think that that sentiment
is still
very much is um
in my observations i think that
sentiment is very much pervasive
in new media discussions and new medias
and digital
social media user generated content in
these subgroups any given subgroup
um where they're demanding people to
think differently about their existence
and that's when we're talking about
latinx media
in the united states where many of these
um
that have been marginalized for such a
long time um
the content that i'm observing is very
much
about pushing back on faulty
understandings of a group
so um i think that the question needs to
be divided
between what happens with latinx media
where
latinx is a numerical minority and i put
air quotes around that
and you can get into that and changing
numbers and so on and so forth
but where it has been either a numerical
minority or historically marginalized
group
and how we see media being used to talk
back to
these norms both for people who have
internalized those norms
like remember that stereotype you saw on
television isn't you
um and to people who are not part of
this group right that there is a very
complicated question there
and i look forward to your work if
you're doing
um research on latinx populations and
latinx media
in latin america um
how those voi what voices
have not historically been heard and
um how one of the papers that i have is
on target versus total marketing
and basically the oxymoron of the total
market
that inevitably we have this idea that
we are all
x whatever x is but at the same time
we're constantly pursuing this
individuated conversation
so i i look forward to hearing about
how media technologies are used to tell
which stories
and which stories are getting more
coverage
in in any given
community and population does that
answer your question
is that yeah and and there's definitely
some issues that we're we're speaking
about um it's a small group that with
tamara freshers was also here as a lot
of grad students
and diego also all thing is here too uh
but yeah
we're definitely talking about these
issues about also what it means to be
latin america and latinx
and what maybe the ideas of
globalization or presentation mean there
so definitely thank you for the answer
absolutely and i would also always
always invite you that every theory that
you read regardless of who wrote it ask
yourself what does this mean for our
population and what does this mean
our population of interest right our
population of interest and our
media does it fit does it not fit and if
it doesn't fit
how does the theory need to evolve
and that is the voice that i'm very
excited to hear from you
i'm going to turn on another light
because i'm getting super dark in here
thank you
anybody else thoughts
hi charisse great talk thank you um
i'd like to hear more about your
critical research on romeo and juliet
could you share that with us
i would thank you i research is a is a
big word
i don't know if um it qualifies
but um bob thompson and i have been
running this podcast
for three years now we call it a pop
trash podcast it was fired because we
were both
fast and furious fans and fast and
furious had been largely discarded
by the uh by academics right and
by people in the public anyway they're
like oh fast and furious what are they
on now like 23
like no they're on nine and it's coming
out in may
um but uh then we started thinking more
deeply about conversations that were not
happening um because we had dismissed it
as trash
uh so then we talked about keanu reeves
we did a whole case study on
a whole star study on keanu reeves i
watched like 30 plus keanu reeves films
um and really started to develop a
theory
of keanu reeves as a celebrity icon
and the um
[Music]
and and what he was bringing to the role
and how he reflected
um american
and human uh values right very much a
richard dyer
um star study classic celebrity star
study
so then we were stuck like what are we
going to do next well we wanted to do
something that's a bit more
feminine because we had done fast and
furious very masculine
and we do talk about keanu reeves
playing with gender roles but it's still
kind of masculine dominated and so that
brought us to
um we're thinking about doing a star
study of madonna
um we were thinking about doing uh old
testament new movie and just look at
movies from the old testament
um i'm a big fan of the book of esther
just on a personal note
um but then we went with romeo and
juliet specifically looking at the
remakes of romeo and juliet
right so romeo and juliet is it's not
pop trash but
it is kind of ultimately post-modern
right we all know the romeo and juliet
story sometimes because we are required
to read it in class
um but it's become such a um
almost cliche piece of culture
that we can now play with it and so we
are looking at remakes of romeo and
juliet starting in west side story so
starting with west side story
and looking at how the
um how the
choices of the writer and director as
well as the cultural time
right what's happening in the culture at
the time infuse and change and reflect
this story
because romeo and juliet is such a it's
such a go-to
that anybody can layer something onto it
so we start with romeo and ju we start
with west side story
and then we do the zephyrelli right so
these two very early ones
um zepharelli is very true to the
narrative and is generally critically
acclaimed
then we jump ahead and do tromeo and
juliet
i don't know if anybody is familiar with
trauma films but they uh
toxic avenger it's like gross out
b-movie
really inappropriate stuff like
incest and mutilation and basically all
the stuff that made shakespeare great
uh that's the tagline of the film but
then thinking through
how this kind of gross out punk culture
of 1996 uh directed by james gunn by the
way of
marvel fame um
reflected the sort of punk grunge
uh diy culture that was happening
in media specifically through um
phenomena
like video cameras also mtv
and just you know seeing how this kind
of um
gen x uh
gross out version of romeo and juliet
then we do of course the bas lerman
uh that's with with leonardo dicaprio
and claire danes
that's that's the one um then we also
look at some other films we look at
romeo must die
which generally is considered pop trash
we look
at um uh we did shakespeare in love we
did
nomio and juliet we did private romeo so
if you haven't seen private romeo
it's also an independent film um
but it was shot basically it was
released three months before don't ask
don't tell
is repealed so it's shot in the midst of
don't ask don't tell
and features two boys two young men
um in a boys military academy
falling in love while simultaneously
performing the play
so at any given time you're starting to
see how the play itself
is simultaneously
um work in the classroom and like try to
understand this language
um but also very much intimate and lived
through this young love um
so that was great um we also watched
david and fatsuma
which i was very honored to be able to
expose that to bob for the first time he
never knew that film
and it's basically uh israeli-palestine
in
uh um romeo and juliet
in jerusalem
um starring martin landau it's martin
landau's last film along with tony
curtis's last film
so it's it's really weird but um
it's it's fascinating and just looking
at how this story has been retold
over and over and over again um and i'm
trying to remember who
the the character from gossip girl
he's british and he plays like the evil
one i can't remember
anyway he plays tibblet in the 2013
version and in an interview he said the
thing about romeo and juliet is that
every generation deserves their own
um so we take that language and start
looking at
how are we telling generational stories
through this story that we all know
and it has been a joy and thank you for
asking um
so you know
like comment subscribe you can find it
at criticalandcurious.com
i'm about to release episode 9
which is shakespeare in love and then
episode 10 which is nomio and juliet
and then we close with the 2013 and uh
romeo and juliet in harlem
if you haven't seen that one that's the
first one it was um
sold as you know advertised as
the first all cast of color
to do romeo and juliet so you know
they're all the
who who's doing a romeo and juliet remix
anybody everybody
please get to it give me more
um we have a question from the q a yes a
couple of them actually
um so this is from muhammad reza nassiri
hello and thanks for the talk in that
chart that is also on page nine
where you consider the evolving
interaction between
top down and bottom up norm setting
so for example twitter first
started to adopt hashtags in the system
at a systematic way
after iran's 2009 protests and then
later in the protests in arab countries
and that changed the structure as well
as the use of twitter
and also the whole adoption of hashtag
even in our everyday conversations
this kind of interaction is especially
more powerful in the new interactive
media
as for example the norms of filmmaking
were mostly set
by a few studios in a more top-down
manner
as a result the norms of filmmaking have
also changed and evolved
very slowly and actually mostly
unchanged since then
but the norms of new media and hence our
communication
is evolving faster due to this constant
two-way interaction
[Music]
yes
[Laughter]
uh yeah no i completely agree and again
i think the accelerated speed
at which we see things change are is
essential like we have to acknowledge
that what is current today will not be
current tomorrow and that that level of
evolution is not um is is new
it's definitely new um i will also say
it's funny that you bring up
film because one of the papers that
is it's in a book called mediated
millennials and looking
at how youth generated music videos
and from 2007 to 2013
and looking at how in 2007 it was very
much adopting
uh tropes from film and kids were just
trying to like
remake their favorite music videos but
then by 2013 we see this real emphasis
on kind of individualized and selfie
culture which was not neces which then
like
wrapped into the music videos that were
being made at the mainstream level
so to things advance quickly because
they can be
shared in my opinion can be shared so
quickly right so you have that back and
forth
um and now you see that
older mediums uh desperate to survive
are
mining whatever the young people are
doing
in hopes that that will bring them into
the theater um
i think it really comes down to um
institutionalization right film was
institutionalized before it was required
to change
uh it had 30 40 years before television
came along and then television was
like we're taking this good luck
and then film was forced to change as
opposed to
um other technologies as opposed to like
twitter and social media
um their institutional power just comes
from the
number of users they have in my opinion
um
you know and the fact that they've got
whatever hundreds of engineers that can
turn around a new
a new skin like every six months stop at
facebook just stop it
sorry thank you uh kelly had their hand
up for a while and so did ambar
i believe i'm pronouncing this correctly
please correct me if i'm wrong
yeah thank you for the talk um i was
curious when you've been thinking about
relationships with media
if you've thought about people's
relationships with media that talk back
like robots like how do you think from a
psychology perspective
people should be thinking about their
relationships with like that level of
interactive media
sure um and i think before we even get
to robots we can talk about
um we can i guess alexa is a robot um
we can talk about gps right we can talk
about
uh reciprocal and i would argue that
those are very much reciprocal media
um i i love talking about magnetic tape
right because i push
play and it goes i push stop and stops
and like that was
that was i argue unprecedented um at a
mass level
i think what's really similarly with
video games i think
um you know before we jump into what was
it
her she her with scarlett johansson
um or this futurama episode where
fry falls in love with a robot um i
think
we have to think about this nuanced
expectation of communication
and the fact that i say go and it goes i
want something and it gives it to me um
the fact that two things
you know the fact that we can have our
emotions immediately our needs not
emotions but our needs emotion
immediately gratified
um is something that we have to remember
like we have to be conscious of it um
and so i'm not saying don't use robots
i'm saying that robots are not humans
reeves and nass would say we might
forget um
and secondly oh crap did i lose it i had
such a good one
um oh i do talk about um the
availability paradox and this idea that
when the world is at your fingertips
we don't pursue it right i track this
back to like cable
news right um cable news channels are
all within the same like 10
channel spectrum right like if you go up
two channels you go from
msnbc to fox news uh so you can
literally push a button
and have a completely world view
completely different worldview presented
to you
but we don't and i have so many students
that come into my office like
i don't know what this word means i'm
like yo you're literally sitting with
your phone
all you have to do is say siri define
this word
and it will tell you this word but
instead we're like oh just it's just too
much stuff it's just too much
so i would argue that a we have to
realize that that responsiveness is
is is a privilege right as opposed to
the norm as opposed to the standard
um but at the same time how are we using
that responsiveness to improve our own
lives
or how are we becoming a little bit lazy
um by not utilizing the full potential
coming back to potential promise and
practice
using the full potential of a given
responsive technology
um and in the case of robots i mean
do we have robots that aren't connected
to the internet anymore
i mean i assume so but um
this uh yeah the question comes down to
what does the robot do
what does the robot do for you and why
is that robot in your life
and i would argue that that's the same
question we need to ask for any
technology
is that a good answer
yeah thank you thank you amber
yeah thank you well mine is a little uh
like it's about my uh thesis in my video
so i don't know like if everybody will
want to hear it but here we go
so basically what i'm trying to do is
like comparing the way people
create their autobiographical narratives
with auto
biographical biographies generated by
algorithms
in social platforms oh yeah so you but
the thing is like i don't have a
psychology background
and like i am trying to think about like
you know in
psychology it has been recognized that
the formation of life narratives uh
plays a crucial role
in the construction construction of
personal identity right
i was like just i was wondering if you
could give me like an
insight where to look at like i saw your
like what your
talk like your ted talk and you're like
there's
anyone how to explore themselves using
like different media
are you trying to see how like
algorithmic
you're narrative you're good you're good
keep going okay okay
how can like algorithmic narratives can
be used as a tool
for reflection rather than a way in
which like machines and companies like
limit our reflectivity so i think you
could give me a good insight
well i do discuss in chapter three on
consumer market cameras and basically
how consumer market cameras allowed us
to create our own autobiographical
visual narratives
easily right like i push a button i have
a picture of this moment and i can line
them all up and create an autobiography
um and so i do talk a little bit you'll
you'll like that chapter because it
gives you a little bit about the
psychology
in how we construct memories through
visual images
um and i do explicitly talk about
algorithmic
um pushing of stuff right so i keep
getting notes from like
shutterfly oh this was your so what you
did four years ago i'm like cool and i
forward it to my friends and i keep
going um or facebook will give you a
whole
pushing your memories back because we
don't often stop to think about
well let me rephrase that some study
said we'll only ever look at 25
of the pictures that we ever took all
right and so this is what i love about
these algorithmic
memories is that it's like oh you shared
it well here look at it because you
weren't going to go back and look at it
so i do think that it meets a real
psychological need
where we get to see and remind ourselves
of things that we had forgotten that we
wanted to remember
um so i do think that the book and
specifically chapter three and i will
say this you know the whole book has
however many hundreds of citations
it is designed as a prior literature
with respect to media
technology and psychology for these nine
technologies
and i think that you will appreciate and
be able to use a lot of the references
that are in
uh chapter three and they'll take you
they'll help you down the right path
um and help you start all that
psychology stuff that you need i promise
thank you of course
there's uh so there's another question
in the q a
um from um corey schweitzberg
you argue in the chapter that we should
avoid overly deterministic
understandings of how media technologies
influence human behavior
for example social media makes you
depressed
considering how interdependent and
convoluted psychosocial and
technological effects
are on people slash users that said
facebook's business model is to
establish and strengthen
uh predictable profitable casual
relationships between
data targeted advertising and user
spending
you use the social media platform to
pursue psychosocial needs
facebook collects your data targets ads
at you hopefully influences your
consumer behavior
and makes money makes money if they
succeed incentivizing facebook book
to optimize their social media
experience to make you
more useful as a data mine and ad
consumer
how do you reconcile the general idea
that technologies don't
dictate behavior with the fact that the
tech giant successfully
measured by multi-billion dollar profits
use ai scientists data analyst analysts
and ux researchers to deliberately
influence user behavior
okay so uh very quickly to i have three
things i want to say one
i don't think they determine behavior
they encourage behavior
and then when we feel good about it
becomes a cycle unto itself right so
they're encouraging this behavior but at
any given point you could turn it off
right we have that free will
you could delete facebook and it keeps
going like goes viral on facebook to
delete facebook
you know it but it encourages this
behavior and when that behavior feels
good then we engage in that behavior so
it is a cycle
in which um the platforms
create one trigger and then that
continues to spin on itself like some
kind of
technological cotton candy um
and and it's sweet i've already gotten
lost in this metaphor i'm really hungry
and this it's dinner time
um so i think it's not necessarily the
technology
but when we look at it from an outside
perspective it would appear that the
technology is determining our behavior
but when we're in it we realize that
we've only been pushed in one direction
and we keep going in that direction
because momentum
um and then until we see that we're
being pushed in that direction we cannot
stop
um the other thing i wanted to mention
regarding keanu reeves is you know as
you talk about facebook
becoming a using human users as a mind
i'm automatically like thinking about
those shots from matrix where the humans
become the battery for the robots right
and until we realize that we're in this
space we cannot walk away from it
um and i would argue that
this is something i say over and over
and over again if social media
is not meeting your needs if a given
platform is not meeting your needs
you've got to let it go right you gotta
like this
you have to and it's it's easier said
than done
um i will say i so when i um
when i i had um my child three years ago
i started a new instagram page for him
because i didn't want to be one of those
people who's like their baby just took
over their
social media feed and that's not to crap
on those people i just didn't want to be
that person
so i created a new um profile for him
and i post a picture every day
so like he's got his own page it's
private we're not trying to make the
baby go viral right
it's private it's only family and
friends
so he has a very limited circle and now
i'm on that one
all the time because all it is is family
and like smithsonian zoo pictures
uh and dolly parton's imagination
library and so
regularly i get to the end of the
internet like that's not
a thing you're never supposed to get to
the end of the internet that's the
amazing situation of infinite scrolling
but i get to the end of the internet all
the time and instagram's like you have
nothing new to look at
i'm like great all right so i would just
encourage you know
we have to be able to see how our
behavior is being manipulated
it's been manipulated since you know
newspapers right this sensationalism
yellow journalism all of that stuff
was trying to foster outrage and anger
and policy change and
popular change um through encouraging it
now it's much more interactive it's
almost infinite
you know it's just accelerated but those
same
[Music]
that same willingness we have and i feel
like i'm using willingness wrong so let
me just finish this sentence
that same willingness or willing
acquiescence and i do talk about this
willing acquiescence i tie back to the
theatrical film
like we willingly give over our
consciousness to theatrical film we sit
in there
we turn off our phones we separate
ourselves from the outside world
and we say to the filmmaker to the
screen
show me what you want me to see
is it surprising that we would do that
for social media as well
that's it i got deep i got deep but i
feel like that's where i got to end
like anything more it's just i'm only
going to be repeating myself
um well actually i i wanted to just
follow up on that
and and and i think it connects somewhat
with the follow-up question
that that's in the q a um and it is
you know while i was reading um
[Music]
i was thinking about all of the the kind
of
um public conversation
about um about the 2016
election and about just the
the siloing of of different sectors of
society through social media
um and um
i'm just curious to hear your your take
on that kind of conversation about like
whether
you know it's in some ways it's um
similar to
you know the i don't know if you
remember the organization that
pmrc's that was oh yeah the parent music
resource coalition we watched that zap a
congressional hearing in class
yes so um you know is this
is the conversation around um
uh the the kind of very dangerous
fracturing
and polarization of society via
social media um uh
is it just a new version
of the the kind of conversations that
were going on
with the pmrc and others claiming that
um that punk rock and
and heavy metal were creating violence
in in society um or is there something
you know that is due to the
the the nature of these technologies the
speed
the the scale that actually
um where there are actual
potentially very negative effects
broadly in society well just to let you
know you guys all know
that uh to hearken back to the pmrc
prince invented sex
you know that right like that that's
that's what happened
and tipper gore was angry about it
prince invented sex
um i think that i so i do make the
argument about silos as it relates to
cable
because usually when we're talking about
these siloing and these echo chambers
we're comparing them to the three
network system when it was abc cbs and
nbc
providing all national content so when
we had three outlets
three television outlets yeah you it was
a consensus conversation um but we're
not talking about
you know the hundreds of partisan papers
that were happening in
1700 and there's a great visualization
i'm
happy to find it i've got it in there in
some of my class notes about the rise
and fall of american newspapers
and you start to see like how many there
were just like everybody had a newspaper
that was
every partisan perspective that they
wanted between
1700 and 1800 and then around 1800 they
start to homogenize and like well
homogeneous but you know aggregate into
your big papers
and then around like 2000 they just
start to die off
um but it's a really beautiful
visualization and i think
that what's lost in this dots is that
each of those
newspapers was a unique perspective and
each of them were warring against
another newspaper in a given area
so when we see the siloing of
communities and i was just participating
in a reddit science panel
on social media
political ideology and identity that we
see this siloing rise and fall
um when is it going to fall again i
don't know i can't predict that
but i think it's important to realize
that
when we're talking about partisanship
now um we're comparing it to television
we're comparing it to network television
we're not comparing it to
cable television which you know
diversified the spectrum to the point
where people could find whatever they
wanted
uh we're not comparing it to partisan
newspapers from the 18th century
um so i think that that historical lens
is important that
we consistently drift into our
ideological echo chambers because it
feels good
um one of the arguments i make i was um
delivered the faculty address to my to
the incoming class
at syracuse in 2017. i i make this
argument that we are not amoebas
but we will behave like one so if the
mass
will inevitably go in directions that
make them feel better and away from
things that don't make us feel better
but as humans we have that ability
and i think someone here who is at
victor zt
zhang says i'm not sure if we have free
will we're just pieces of a complex
machine that seems facebook and
platforms have our behavior
all right uh the problem is we can't let
it go because of how it stimulates us
right that we
see um we're moving in these
fashions but we need to be able to say
stop
um and on that note i will just use this
to self-promote not self-promote but um
beg if anybody's interested my students
this year are
interviewing people who are
demographically different from them on
four different
categories about their american dreams
and then they're turning these
30 to 40 to 45 minute conversations into
bite-sized media content so by the end
of this year
we'll have 175 american dreams
that really only take one minute to
consume and it has been
the students have really enjoyed it
because they're being paired with people
that they
um would never engage with um
because they because they're
demographically different because we
tend to homogenize into groups that are
similar with us
but then in these conversations they're
realizing about how much similarity they
have
so if anybody wants to participate you
can go to charisselapri.me and fill out
the form i think it's right below the
book promotion just scroll down it's
like the second post or something
um and i would love to pair you with a
student a media student a professional
media student who would like to turn
your
autobiography amber into uh into
bite-sized media content
i also was part of a conversation i was
a consultant for buzzfeed and procter
gamble doing this thing called talk
about bias
where people were paired with strangers
to talk about bias
and i think the potential versus the
promise versus the practice of social
media
is one wherein the potentials we can
engage with anyone around the world
the promise is we will be told that our
needs will be met
and the practice is we engage with the
people we want to
all right but i think we need to revisit
that potential but the potential itself
is scary and i will mention this briefly
my stepfather when he got on facebook
friended everyone everyone and he was
like i'm gonna talk to the world and i
know people here here and here
everyone felix i'm sorry if you're
watching
everyone then all of a sudden they start
messaging me with their creepy messages
and they're like i'm friends with your
father and i'm like dude
stop then he realized that it's a weird
weird weird space and now he's not on
facebook anymore
so i think you know we have to we can
use
social media as they say as victor
mentioned in the
chat we can use social media for our own
needs and we have to remember that we
can take control
and at the same time if we need like
start a new facebook i have another
facebook for my cats
that only has 10 friends it's great so
you know like do with it what you want
remember
you don't have to let facebook or
twitter
or whichever other algorithm-based
platform
is satisfying um
to define your only usage
that was a long walk i don't remember
what the original question was
right are there any we're almost out of
time but i just want to
just see if there are any other
questions out there uh i will say
there's a couple in the chats
so i'll just hit those roya apparently a
distant relative of those worked on
romeo and juliet and yiddish
that's cool i will say one of our
choices on the romeo
and juliet one was only was american so
there are a lot that we did not get into
it had to be
so you know like there's literally 200
in our database
um globally and so we just cut had to
start cutting things down so we cut them
down
for american productions or
joint but they had to have american
production so i
look forward to watching that one um
amardeep again correct me if i'm wrong i
come from a decade of an engineering
background and media studies a bit
foreign yet fascinating during your talk
you repeatedly thought
i repeatedly thought how i my dad and my
four-year-old interact with various
media forms
loved it awesome absolutely and like
just had
my book is dedicated to diane and
constantine diane is my mother and
constantine is my son
and the lion i say is um who
remind who helped me see the past and
the future
uh and i think that those
intergenerational concepts
are intergenerational components are so
important
um and
anna was our last comment i found it
really interesting the notion the end of
the internet
i'm an editor based in mexico city and
one of my collaborators suggests that
the end or limits of the internet may be
where there is no signal for example in
indigenous communities yeah sure
do you think critical thinking may be
useful or which methodological tools
to integrate them on the internet from
an anti-non-post colonial perspective
well that is a conversation for a talk
unto itself
and i hope uh professor baldwin you do
uh you'll you'll bring me in on that
conversation as well
um you know i just i
participatory media also something i
learned at mit
we have to bring in the people who are
using it
to have these conversations and so you
know the only
anti-colonialist perspective that
involves a colonized group
foregrounds and centers said colonized
group or
previously colonized group i should i'll
figure out that language later we'll
correct that in post
um and i think that so much coming back
to some of our other points about
media companies mining us for data
there's something to be said there's a
dot to be connected
with the way in which we have
historically treated certain groups
mining them for their resources mining
them for their labor mining them for
their land and leaving them barren
um if we start thinking about this
phenomenon across
perspective across time across groups
i think that we can begin to tackle the
questions of today
with a more nuanced approach
ooh that's good let's close there that's
fantastic
thank you so much cherise um and
um oh is that oh andrew brought him okay
uh let's see let's uh alexa
do you want to come upstairs and say hi
to student alexa announce do you want to
come upstairs and say hi to students
oh alexa's angry oh i would have to go
get him
dude i mean i'm happy too
let's see if you have to go you have to
go um
but i'm i'm happy to collect him um
or i could just show you my phone
let's see here um
he's very sweet uh
let's see um
here he is go ahead all right hold on
i'm sorry this is probably not a good
use of our last minutes together but
um he had a really good one the other
day
okay
oh okay a store that poops in the potty
yeah we're working on potty training and
i don't think there's any technology
that helps you with potty training
that's that's what we have come
you know what works with potty training
m ms that's pretty much it
it's like if your diapers dry you get m
ms that's all
we're very low tech yes
all right well thank you so much therese
um
and um look forward to reading the rest
of your book
thank you so much thank you so much for
having me i really really appreciate it
it was an
honor to come home